I had to pee for at least 2 and 1 half
hours of this three and a half hour long
Odyssey and I never got up to take a
break it's the best compliment I can
give it seriously feel free to put that
on the Blu-ray box when this comes out
on home release if physical media is
still around at that
[Music]
point so killers of the flower moons the
new Martin score sty film takes place in
the 1920s and is the true story of a
mass murder plot against the oage Native
American tribe so of the mains Leonardo
decaprio Robert dairo and Lily Gladstone
I'm going to talk about dairo first
because you know how it is where they
aim to make a very humanized villain
it's a very big thing nowadays humanize
your villains I thought this was an
incredible take on that cuz you're
dealing with the head of the snake who
had a horrific plan of mass murder he
comes across as a man of the community
someone who the oage people called
friend there's a wolf in sheep's
clothing and then there's a snake who
has everyone convinced that he's a puppy
until the point of performing is Robert
dairo is 80 years old still commanding a
scene you have three main actors in here
all of which command the scenes there in
sometimes they're in scenes together at
age 80 dairo can be like I'm done I'm
going to phone it in here it is three
Oscar contenders in this film that I can
think of and that's just onc screen
performances I don't mind saying this is
one of Leo DiCaprio's best performances
that's a pretty high bar too maybe it's
a recency biased thing but when watching
you know how you watch a movie and you
can usually pick out like that's the
Oscar Sizzle reel like if he's nominated
that's the clip there were a few moments
in this movie where that could be the
case the movie does leave me with
questions about his character there's
something they're a little vague about I
feel like Hugh Jackman from from The
Prestige how does he not know but it
doesn't really give you the answer and
it bothered me it it's just I just
wanted the answer what was in the bottle
I know it was bad I just want to know
what it was and does he know it was bad
and if not how the film does illustrate
early on that this guy is easily
manipulated fact remains having
DiCaprio's character who's I mean he's a
real guy Ernest Burkhart having Ernest
Burkhart be the main character in this
film in which he's part of the plot to
kill his wife's family also his wife is
being poisoned also they love each other
that is actually a gutsy call the they
love each other element but you look at
the movie it doesn't work without it
because how else does it work it love
makes people blind and that's kind of
the point now Lily Gladstone's the one
who
actually I dare say makes it all work
without her if she wasn't in it you
really would be seeing this film and the
situation Through The Eyes of shitty
people she's the very personification
and lesson here which is if you so love
and trust someone or something this much
you will want to look past the truth
which is killing you the heart overrides
the brain when Martin scorsi says well
this is a story of of love it is it's
the darker side of it doesn't make it
any less real actually makes it more
real than most but honestly if all three
Leonardo DiCaprio Robert dairo Lily
Gladstone if they all get nominations
this year I wouldn't be the least bit
surprised and if they don't doesn't
matter doesn't mean they didn't crush it
just means the academy is the academy as
for the 3 and 1 half hour long run time
I legitimately meant what I said in the
intro of this video is a true story it
illustrates the point that point being
in terms of time management I thought
this film did it very well cuz I never
felt there was an opportune or Optimum
moment where I could take a break if it
wasn't a murderous plan going down it
was the scheming of a murderous plan if
it wasn't the scheming of a murderous
plan it was seemingly small talk with a
lot of nuance around that makes the
world a feel lived in B you're still
seeing that which allowed the plan to go
down just I never felt like there was
downtime in here example Oppenheimer
3-hour film this year I thought was
great I felt killers of the flower Moon
actually used its time better than
Oppenheimer did though it's longer may
sound strange but it is what it is
that's how I take it in gred even at 3
and 1 half hours I was left with that
feeling of this could probably be a 6-h
hour miniseries especially at the end
when it's like on this date were you
with so and so and was he with so and so
and I'm like who's so and so and so and
so I don't know I'm terrible with the
names of people I've actually met in
real life I don't remember that person's
name The wrap-up of this film is very
Scorsese as well most movies like this
would have the text come up and that'd
be it Scorsese does it in a more
interesting and we'll say fun way and
that kind of shows how scorsi can thread
that needle a lot of directors when
dealing with heavy subject matter that
is a true story you can almost feel them
be like okay we're going to be in this
box we're not going to Veer from it no
one's going to laugh it'll be
informative but it will be safe scores
can throw some fun moments or humor in
there that don't feel disrespectful not
a lot of directors would take that on in
the end I thought the film was really
well done it's well acted it's heavy
subject matter that makes it worth a
watch alone cuz if you're like me you
didn't hear about this outside of
entertainment like with Tulsa thanks
public education but the execution of
said subject matter is packed with
Incredible performances by talented
actors who clocked into work no doubt it
sticks with you and that's important in
a movie like this it has layers in which
it haunts you I think killers of the
flower Moon worth watching and worth
buying on Blu-ray all right so killers
of the flower moon have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more